at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal and personality
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free
they'll even pick it up from you if you
don't love it and now my dear listeners
helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at slash helixsleep.com
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.comtim
that's helix h h-e-l-i-x sleep dot com
slash tim for up to 200 off so
check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim
this episode is brought to you by
freshbooks thousands of listeners and a
lot of the contractors i use
and my readers use freshbooks if you've
been thinking about turning your
part-time side business into a full-time
small business or big business for that
matter
you may be feeling some extra
uncertainty these days and
that's obviously completely natural
there are a lot of questions that can
come up how do you create a professional
appearance and experience who can help
you with support how do you manage the
billing and all of that
but still focus on the primary work of
your business and on growing your
business
freshbooks is an all-in-one invoicing
and accounting solution
it does a lot more than that that helps
you take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best sign up flows
in the business i've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years
and they can help you too i've met the
founders i've looked at this product
very closely with automated invoicing
billable time and expense tracking
and an intuitive dashboard that ties it
all together it's like having a
full-time financial assistant with you
every step of the way
you can create customize and send
branded and professional looking
invoices in about 30 seconds
you get paid up to twice as fast with
fees as low as 1 percent using ach
payments on freshbooks
it's a fast easy and secure way for
clients to pay you for your work
and pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets freshbooks apart
is their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast
and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have
your questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now
but your ability to build a business
that you're passionate about that you're
proud of
doesn't have to be one of those things
business owners all over the world rate
freshbooks as the easiest accounting
software to use
try it out check it out for free for 30
days at freshbooks.com
tim just enter tim ferriss in the how
did you hear about us section
again that's freshbooks.comtim to check
it out
and try it for free for 30 days one more
time freshbooks.com
tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of
the tim ferriss show where it's my job
to deconstruct world-class performers
of all different types from every
possible nook and cranny every possible
industry or sector
or profession to help you tease out the
books
the habits the belief systems the
structures
and so on that you can test and apply in
your own lives my guest today i've
wanted to have on for a very long time
rabbi
lord jonathan sax at rabbi sachs on all
social
he is an international religious leader
philosopher and respected
moral voice he was the chief rabbi of
the uk and the commonwealth from 1991 to
2013
and the recipient of the 2016 templeton
prize in recognition of his
exceptional contributions to affirming
life's spiritual dimension
if you're looking for some hope amidst
the fear these days
some light in the darkness of
uncertainty my hope is that
this episode provides some much needed
medicine rabbi sax has been described by
his royal highness the prince of wales
as a light unto this nation and by
former
british prime minister tony blair as an
intellectual giant
he is an award-winning author of more
than 30 books
just incredible including not in god's
name his new book
morality subtitle restoring the common
good in divided times
recently became a bestseller in the uk
and it is now available in
north america he is a frequent and
sought-after contributor to radio
television and the international press
and a renowned public speaker for
reasons that will be very obvious once
we get into the conversation
and he has degrees from both cambridge
and oxford universities as well as 18
count them 18 honorary degrees he was
knighted by her majesty the queen in
2005 and took his seat in the house of
lords in october 2009
born in 1948 in london he's been married
to his wife
elaine since 1970 they have three
children and several
grandchildren you can find him at
rabbissacs.org on all social at rabbi
sax
without further ado please enjoy
this wide-ranging conversation that i so
much enjoyed
with rabbi lord jonathan sax
rabbi saks welcome to the show tim great
to be with you
i'm so thrilled to finally connect i
have pages and pages and stacks and
stacks of questions for you we'll see
how much we can get to
and i wanted to start with a
perhaps unusual starting point and that
is asking about
yellow ties i found under the category
of strange habits
a note from your wife of 50 years in the
times uk
he always wears a yellow tie when he's
due to give important speeches
or on special occasions so i wouldn't
expect you to wear one right now but
is there any truth to that statement and
could you
elaborate if so 100
tim i always used to wear silver ties
this kind of dignified thing that
ministers of religion do
and i was i had a huge but huge
collection of silver ties
then at a certain point in time
i'm not sure whether it was 2016 or a
little earlier than that
the world began to fall apart
and that was when i realized that part
of my job was not just to speak or to
write
but to cheer people up and
i think little miss or little mr
cheerful
has to be colored yellow so i thought
wearing a yellow tie
cheers people up and by and large
consciously or subconsciously it does
however you know i also do something
else i must have about 50
yellow ties but when i'm doing a really
really difficult speech i will wear a
yellow tie
that was given to me by a very close
friend
my friends noticing that i wear yellow
ties
tend to make a present of a yellow tie
and
when i feel i am wearing something
that a friend gave me in love you know
it just makes the speech so much
easier but can i tell you tim about the
yellow tie that i wore
when you and i did ted together in
vancouver three years ago
yes please you know the the there's a
kind of rehearsal
for ted talks about a month in advance
it takes place in chelsea in in new york
near chris anderson's apartment and
just before me there was a gentleman
practicing his speech a gentleman called
ray dalio
who's been on your show i think uh ray
is the dead
head of the world's largest uh hedge
fund i think
and ray who is a hugely wise and
brilliant and a successful man and a
very
open man was absolutely devastated he
was in
a state of real nerves during the
rehearsal so i was
shaking as i went up to um
to deliver my speech and i delivered my
rehearsal and chris anderson at the end
said jonathan i like the speech
but what about the tie because
apparently
no one wears a tie at ted
i said chris i have read the
instructions
and i have met you halfway you will see
that i am not wearing
long dangling earrings isn't that good
enough
anyway eventually chris and i reached
a compromise which was that i would wear
my yellow tie for my ted speech and as
soon as that was over
i d tied and remained tireless for the
rest
of ted
[Laughter]
i i so enjoyed meeting you at ted and i
just have to share
a quick anecdote which which is somewhat
similar so at ted itself i remember they
had constructed
they called it something like the zen
room or the relaxation room which was
basically the on deck
circle for the next few speakers by the
stage
and i went out there to relax at one
point
because of the namesake and i remember i
think it was gary kasparov or casparov
and
a few other icons were just sweating
bullets
and i said to myself if i try to relax
here i'm going to have a complete
nervous
breakdown so i i
shuffled off to some corner to prepare
uh what uh what what what a day that was
uh
seems seems lifetimes ago and
the next hop is going to be a bit uh
non-linear of course because that's the
way these conversations tend to go
i'd like to revisit a line from your
profile and thank you so much for
for answering so many questions for
tribal mentors
my last book and the the question was
about your purchase of 100
or less that has most positively
impacted your life in the last
say six months and the answer is
interesting but not as interesting as
the line
that explains it your answer at the time
was without a shadow of a doubt buying
noise-canceling earphones uh bose in
this case
and the line that i want to explore is
these are the most religious objects
i've ever come across
because i define faith as the ability to
hear the music beneath the noise
and i had never heard or read anyone
define
faith that way and i don't know if that
definition has changed for you but could
you speak
to what you mean by that and how you
arrived at that perhaps
what i mean is incidentally you'll
you'll call me back on that
tim because um i felt bad about it from
that day to this because actually
noise cancelling earphones cost a little
more than a hundred dollars so i will
give you a one that really only cost ten
dollars
but um what i mean is this you know
when we look at what happens to us
so much of it is noise
you know stuff that happens and doesn't
seem to add up
or make sense in any way somebody once
asked
harold mcmillan the british prime
minister in the 1950s
what is the biggest challenge of being
prime minister
and he replied events dear boy
events so there's so much going on and
you are
buffeted by this wind this whirlwind
of swirling pressures and life can come
to seem
as the book of ecclesiastes calls it
meaningless meaningless all is
meaningless
faith is the ability to go deeper than
that and to sense
the real wonders the miracles that
surround us
the very existence of the universe
is unbelievably improbable the very
existence of
life is even more improbable
the most distinguished mathematician
in britain lord reese astronomer royal
and
the president of the um of the royal
society
once gave me his book called just six
numbers
in which he argues that the entire
existence of the universe depends on six
improbabilities and when you
sense the majesty of existence
of life of beauty of nature
of the human person of love
of becoming a parent those are the
things we tend to miss
because we're so preoccupied by the
noise
and if we could find a way of generating
a
noise reduction system in our minds
we would actually see and sense the
beauty of life
now i once said to richard dawkins
whom i regard as a beloved friend but he
is pretty
angry atheist and i once said to richard
you know richard your problem is you are
tone
deaf you can't hear the music
he gave me a lovely reply he said yes
it's true
i am tone deaf
but there is no music
[Laughter]
so there we are i i i think that's the
difference
really between richard and myself that
that i can hear the music and that music
you'll find in the book of psalms you'll
hear that music
in great poetry and the sonnets of
shakespeare
you'll hear that music in beethoven and
in schubert
and i love it and it's mystical and it's
terrific and i find that you know
wearing those noise-canceling earphones
not just good on planes
it's really good for meditation so i
want to
tie up one tiny loose end before i go to
my next related question but you said
i'll give you one that costs less than
ten dollars
what is the the purchase of less than
ten dollars is there something else that
is positively impacted
absolutely fabulous thing a book
light i love them and i've got lots of
them now
a bug light allows me to read anywhere
at night it allows me to go around the
house without switching the lights on
and hence waking up
it allows me to read without waking my
wife elaine
um it's a perfect perfect
uh you know form and function it's
absolutely magnificent less than ten
dollars
very easy to recharge and
my book light is the joy of my life
beautiful and we will explore books in
many capacities in this conversation i
suspect
you mentioned earlier that part of your
job or you viewed part of your job is
cheering people up
and i want to unfurl that a bit
because i think there's a lot there you
also have already mentioned
and and i brought up music you seem to
have been
sensitive you you have been sensitive to
music since a very
literal music since a very young age
and in one of the many
different articles that i read prior to
this
conversation i found a quote which you
can please
feel free to correct the quote to you
reads as follows
there's a sadness in jewish music a kind
of minor key that i heard when i was two
or three years
old and then it went on later it's an
existential sadness that i can't
eliminate however hard i try that's
probably what allows me to communicate
with people who are unhappy
so first i always like to ask does this
sound like
something you said or does it have truth
to it and if so
could you expand on it the um first two
to three years
of my life we we didn't have our own
home
uh we lived with my grandparents
and my grandfather who was a businessman
he had a wine shop
also actually owned a synagogue it was
very tiny little synagogue
but it was just down the road from from
where we were living
and that was my first experience of
synagogue life and i
i imagine that almost every single
person in that synagogue
was a refugee i mean this is uh you know
um early 1950s
they'd come in from the war my late
father's family
and he himself came from poland
so you had people who had been through
the most searing experiences
had encountered absolute dislocations
in some cases lost their families
in all cases were struggling to make
themselves at home
in a new land my father's favorite line
from the bible was moses
calling his son gershom saying i'm a
stranger in a strange land and that
that's what my father felt and you could
hear
that sadness in the music of the
synagogue and it was my first encounter
with music my first encounter with
synagogue music with music as prayer
and i find it there in most jewish music
not all jewish music but most of it
and it comes from century after century
after century
of suffering now of course you can break
out beyond that
but uh you know it's it's just there i
don't know
can i i don't know if you feel it in
those
three great jewish musicians of the 20th
century the late
leonard cowan and to some extent bob
dylan and to some extent
paul simon um not really you don't
really feel it but i feel it
still in things like irving berlin and
george gershwin
there is uh you know a powerful note of
sadness there
uh that to my mind is is part of the
signature
of being jewish do you find that sadness
in you to be enabling
more enabling or disabling in your
ability to
help others and to affect change in the
world
50 years ago i met and married
well 52 years ago i met and 50 years ago
i married
elaine and elaine is the most
she is sunshine i mean that's just what
she is
and we were completely different people
i i actually said this in ted i said
that i recognized somebody who was
totally and absolutely different from me
and i said it's the people not like us
who make us
grow so without elaine i might have
become a very sad human being a
depressive human being
but to be married to somebody that
profoundly
positive not in a superficial way at all
but somebody just
affirming of life and and always seeing
the
the positive possibilities of any
situation
nothing ever got elaine down
and it was that relationship that love
that marriage
that kept me from being overwhelmed by
the sadness
you've mentioned before and i think in
in some respect this is
on a similar theme of sort of
transmuting
pain or sadness into something useful
in the world you've mentioned that one
of the most inspirational
books you've read is the choice this is
a book that fewer people
will recognize compared to say some of
victor frankl's work but could you
please describe the choice and why it is
meaningful to you
well you know this book came out not
that long ago i don't know how how many
years ago maybe
four or five years ago i don't know but
it came out
and i didn't recognize the name at all
and here was another holocaust book and
there are
tens and maybe hundreds of thousands of
them and i try and read somebody i can't
possibly read all
but this was getting such positive
reviews
it became a bestseller in the states and
then actually became a bestseller here
in britain as well
that i thought i must read this and as i
read it i i could not believe what i was
reading
because this was edith eager's first
book
and she was 90 years old
and she was in essence a female
victor frankel not quite
victor frankel in the sense that viktor
frankl already worked out
his entire response to evil and and to
grief
while he was in auschwitz it took edith
some
years to come to terms with it she had
to go back there she had to wrestle with
it but she did eventually wrestle with
it
and became a psychotherapist like victor
frankl
and then helped people
cope with situations
of the kind that she had coped with in
the concentration camps
and what edith actually went through
which is more than defranco did was not
just
auschwitz but the death march
immediately after the germans left
auschwitz they forced
any prisoner who could walk to join the
death march and most of them died on the
way
and read her account of that as she was
actually kept alive only
by the fact that her sister was there
and two of them kept their
respective spirits up but i mean
you know it's almost impossible to
imagine anyone surviving
those kind of horrendous conditions and
that kind of evil
and yet somehow she worked it through
and she used that experience to work
through the pain the fears the anxieties
of other people and essentially
her philosophy was very very simple
and not unlike victor frankl's which is
whatever
happens to us we always
have a choice we always have a choice as
to how
to see ourselves in relation to what's
happening to us
nobody can take away our mind nobody can
take away how we
define the situation and it is that
choice
that's the very essence of human freedom
liberty
and dignity and of course in the book
she talks not only about her experiences
in auschwitz but how she used those to
deal with
her patients on on the west coast in the
united states
i found this an astonishingly inspiring
book
you know just when you thought there was
very little new to be learned from the
holocaust
here was the story of this extraordinary
woman
i've enjoyed following you over the
years
since we first met and i
also came into this interview feeling
quite insecure in a sense because
i have on one hand at one end of the
spectrum
amongst my friends people like sam
harris who i love dearly
a great friend on the other end of the
spectrum i have deeply religious friends
but i know very little about religion i
don't self-describe as someone who is
particularly religious
how did you choose to become a rabbi i
understand the
the family background but i'm looking at
some of the notes
in front of me and i don't know if this
is accurate but
seems that you you perhaps thought at
some point that you were going to become
an economist or a lawyer
how and why become a rabbi i'm an
economist
monkey there you are
you know 1968 uh
when um simon and garfunkel were
counting the cars on the new jersey
turnpike
and they've all come to look for america
in 1968
the end of my second year at university
at 20 years old
i thought to myself you know i don't
know much about
judaism about religion but i do know
there are lots of distinguished
distinguished rabbis
and so i decided in 1968
summer of to take a plane to the states
and
buy um greyhound bus ticket
uh do they still do that kind of thing
tim it was uh
it was a hundred dollars still exist
hundred dollars unlimited travel
and you know i went around looking for
america
and counting the rabbis not the cars and
i met lots of terrific rabbis
the extraordinary thing was that
almost all of them mentioned a name to
me which i hadn't heard of before
and the name was rabbi menachem mendel
schneerson
who was known as the lubavitcher rebber
he was he was the head of a
a group of jewish mystics called
lubovitches
and they said you must meet him because
he is the great leader of our time
so um i tried to find out where he was
and his
center was in 770 eastern parkway in
brooklyn i went there
and i walked in and i said to the first
person i met i've come three thousand
miles
to meet the laboratory could i please
have an appointment
he absolutely fell about laughing
he said do you know how many thousands
tens of thousands of people
are waiting to have a meeting with the
laboratory he's got tens
hundreds of thousands of followers and
they all want to see him
and so come back next year or 10 years
time and
forget it so i said well look i'm
traveling around on this greyhound bus i
don't know where i'm going to be when
but i do know that i'm going to be in
los angeles because i have an
aunt there and i will be traveling there
so here is the phone number of my aunt
and if the
bubba forever finds that he can see
me please give me a call and let me know
and i'll
come to come back to new york
well i was staying with my aunt several
weeks later
in los angeles in beverly hills
and um sunday night the phone goes
and it's somebody from brooklyn saying
the robber can see you on thursday night
now i i really had to go the only
trouble is i didn't have any money at
all
i was a student and the only way of
getting from beverly hills to brooklyn
by greyhound bus is to travel 72 hours
uninterruptedly which is exactly what i
did i do not recommend this
to anyone but i did travel
i didn't travel for 72 hours and i got
to meet the great man
i'm 20 years old and here he is the man
with tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of followers
and we sat for 20 25 minutes and
it was a life-changing experience and
the interesting thing was that he did
not
really let me ask him questions he asked
me questions he was interviewing me
and he said to me for instance something
like this how many jewish students at
cambridge university i said
i don't know but around a thousand he
said how many jewish students
go to the jewish society get involved in
jewish life i said
about a hundred he said you mean ninety
percent
are just completely disengaged i said
yes
he said what are you doing about it and
i
being very english at the time started a
sentence with the following words
in the situation in which i find myself
which is a really english way of saying
could you
ask me something else please and the
rubber believe it or not it was a very
very
polite man actually interrupted me
in the middle of that sentence and he
said you don't
find yourself in a situation you put
yourself in a situation
and therefore i think you should put
yourself in a different situation
and this was absolutely mind-blowing
there were hundreds of people outside
waiting for their interview and
here is this great man essentially
telling me to become a leader which is
the last thing in the world
i wanted to be and many years later i
said
what i learned at that moment was
that people thought of this great man
as a religious leader
with thousands of followers i said yes
that's true but that's the least
interesting thing about him i said good
leaders
create followers great leaders
create leaders and that
is what he did at that moment and that
moment never left me
it changed my entire life didn't change
it immediately it changed it slowly and
gradually
but when you are told by one of the
greatest spiritual leaders of the 20th
century
you are going to have to lead and you're
going to have to leave because you are
in that situation where you can do
something
that did actually change my life i have
so many questions about
just this exchange that we could talk
about
just this for the rest of this
conversation i promise i won't do that
but let me begin with
perhaps one that is on the mind of many
listeners you mentioned
earlier in our chat being sent six
elements or numbers in the improbability
of the universe and so on
let's talk about tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of followers in
the improbability of getting that phone
call even if you have to speculate maybe
you asked him maybe you found out later
maybe you never did but how or why do
you think you got that phone call it
just seems
so unlikely that that would happen
i think the message got through to him
that an english student from cambridge
university had wandered in
to his center i think he probably told
his followers
to get in touch with the organization in
britain
i think he got somebody to ask have you
heard of this guy
and probably they replied yes we we've
met him once because i had met
a couple of his followers in the
university in cambridge
so i think actually he had a
he had followers all over the world i
think he stayed in very close contact
with him
and it was clear that a couple of his
followers in britain
had decided that maybe this 20 year old
had some gifts that this 20 year old
had no idea that he had so he had a
dossier
coming in potentially to the meeting
i will i will tell you i mean my
life has been made
by three or four maybe half a dozen
friendships
with people who believed in
me more than i believed in myself
and i regard myself as really having
been blessed
by those friendships because this is an
extraordinary thing if somebody thinks
you can do something
that you never believed you could do i i
have a pretty negative self-image
but you know some people have actually
believed in me and
and they've befriended me and they were
the people who
lifted me really on their shoulders to
to where i got to
you mentioned that and i'm going to
butcher the pronunciation here but the
lubavitcher reba that's even remotely
closed
thank you even for a yank i'm doing
pretty well what does that mean
most people will have heard the word
rabbi r-a-b-b-i
if spelled and certainly in american
english
uh what does lebovatcher rebel mean and
what what is the origin of that
designation lubovich was a
a town in russia um a little village in
russia actually not
not that huge can i be the tiniest bit
mischievous actually tim
when i first became please be holy
mischievous yes
when i first became a rabbi one of the
members of my congregation said to me
rabbi you're a rabbi and the hasidim the
jewish mystics have
something called a rubber what's the
difference between a rabbi
and a rebber and i said the difference
is this
when a rebber speaks maybe in front of a
thousand people
everyone believes that he is speaking
just to them when a rabbi speaks
maybe in front of a hundred people
everyone is convinced
that he's speaking to the person next to
them
gives you a little hint does it
uh i got it the word rabbi means my
teacher
so a rabbi teaches he instructs
he educates whereas a rebber
the jewish mystics had a much more sort
of
powerful image of of the rabbi as leader
as somebody who could actually order
them to do things you know
go and live in this country go and do
that that particular
uh job of work so they
endowed their leaders with enormous
authority
of a kind that never existed before in
jewish tradition
and that is what a rubber is a rubber is
a
sort of all-powerful leader of a sect
of jewish mystics how would you explain
what a mystic is whether within the
jewish tradition
or more broadly
and one of the robbers disciples said to
me
when i first went to a study at the
rabbinical seminary having come straight
from studying philosophy at cambridge in
oxford
he said you know the difference between
you and us you look at the universe and
you say the universe
exists does god exist
we look at the world and we say god
exists
but does the universe exist in other
words a mystic
believes in the reality of
things that we see as vague as mystical
as spiritual and so on and so forth
believes in in the in the ultimate
reality of the depths
if you like are mystics
as they are in some instances considered
to have
direct experiences of the divine or
experiences of
transcendence is that a prerequisite
for being considered a mystic in the
jewish tradition they really do
but of course they they do it in a very
very specific way
mystics tend to have experience of the
divine as an
element as a dimension um they're quite
different
for instance from prophets who
experience the divine as a voice
as a call as a charge mystics tend to
they tend to screen out uh the more
material elements of life and
and resonate you know as as you know i'm
sure you've
engaged in meditation and mysticism is
generally a meditative discipline
we were discussing earlier these core
say handful
of mentorships or relationships that
have bolstered you
and through which you found confidence
that you didn't perhaps initially
possess in yourself we've covered
perhaps some of
the highlight stories i'd love to talk
about a
challenging time uh and this is
something that
you mentioned in tribe of mentors
it's the period following the
publication of the dignity of difference
and there are calls for your resignation
headlines in the newspaper uh archbishop
of canterbury and chief rabbi accused of
heresy
can you please explain what happened and
why it was controversial
dignity of difference was my response to
9 11.
9 11 i suppose shook all of us shook the
whole world
but one thing that happened was that the
world economic forum that's normally
held at davos was held
that year in january 2002 i think
uh in new york out of solidarity with
the people of new york and i was there i
used to go to the world economic forum
and on one of the days we went
as religious leaders to ground zero
which was still
smoking away and
the archbishop of canterbury was there
chief raoul
israel was there gurus from india
muslim imams and so on
and we all gave prayers at ground zero
but actually standing there at ground
zero and seeing the sheer
enormity of what happened there left a
huge impact on me and
i suddenly realized here is religion as
hate and here are we standing with
archbishop canterbury with imams with
gurus
religion is love religion has mutual
reconciliation and i said to myself this
has got to be the big
choice of the 21st century and i set
myself to
write a book that would be published
on the first anniversary of 9 11 and
given that this was
the very end of january 2002
i said i must publish a book and it must
be
the strongest possible statement
that i can make stronger than has ever
been made before
of the need of religions to make space
for one another
we can no longer predicate ourselves
on defeating converting or eliminating
the religions that are not ours
and i really felt the time the moment
required that
it did not require conventional gestures
of sadness and grief of course they were
there and they were done and they were
done well but
this needed something new and important
so the book i wrote and it did indeed
appear on the first anniversary of 9 11
so i wrote it
at great speed was far and away the most
radical
i had written up to that time it was not
the most radical i have
written i've subsequently written a book
called not in god's name that is much
more radical
but people do not associate radicalism
with chief rabbis or religious leaders
we are there to defend the faith we're
not there in any way to challenge the
faith
and um i felt i'm sorry i've got to take
that risk
well the book was published people
realized quite how radical it was
and um obviously people felt that i had
gone too far
i don't think i went too far at all i
mean looking back in retrospect
absolutely ridiculous to think i went
too far
but i had to face the fact that a lot of
rabbis a lot of my own rabbis felt just
that
what about it led them to feel that you
went too far
could you give us a few examples or a an
example
i will tell you exactly the key sentence
the key sentence was no religion has a
monopoly
on truth right
in order to um satisfy everyone
because i didn't want to take the book
out of circulation i agreed to do a
second edition
and in the second edition i wrote the
following sentence
no religion has a monopoly
on wisdom and the rabbi said ah wisdom
that's fine oh that's okay
so we were able to we were able to
uh resolve the every single issue with
the book
um it took me three hours to make the
necessary changes
and we brought out a second edition and
that was the end of it don't forget
charles darwin brought out a second
edition of
origin of species for the same reason
that his
his book also created controversy so in
the end we came through it's just you
know when you're in the
when you're in the full heat of it um it
can be a little bit unnerving especially
especially when you realize that your
wife and children are affected by this
and that's a really tough one because
they didn't vote for it if you know what
i mean
but in the end we came through it was
okay i made two
phone calls to rabbi's
senior to me older than me and wiser
than me
and i said was i okay and they both said
yes
and the second that i heard that support
from them one in israel one in america i
realized i was fine
i didn't need to worry about it at all
and there there is one piece of wisdom
that i would share with you and um there
is an
american christian minister who wrote a
book
called the purpose-driven life if you
come across this at all
tim i've heard the title yes i don't
recall the authors
and it has sold over 30 million copies
it's a remarkable
achievement but it has one of the best
opening sentences
in any book i know right up there with
tolstoy's anna karenina
and this is the opening sentence it's
not
about you that is a very powerful
sentence
the second i could understand that this
is not about me this is about people's
anxieties this is
you know all the trauma of 9 11 and so
on and so forth
the second i had two friends saying
you're okay i was able to get through
the rest and
it turned out actually to be quite minor
was the euro k so reassuring because
it was an indication that all will be
okay in the end and it was a a
reassurance from
people with broader experience of life
or was it you're
okay in the sense of we we support you
that neither neither neither these were
people
far to the right of me much more you
know conservative
than me but they understood that what i
said was perfectly within the parameters
of jewish belief
here is a principle tim that um
i hope your listeners will will think
about because
it's one of the most powerful life
tools that i've ever come across
[Music]
what happens when you're in a situation
in which you have done
something that has generated widespread
disapproval how do you deal with that
and i thought about this long and hard
and eventually i came up with a
principle which has been a lifesaver to
me
and which makes a great deal of sense
it says win the respect
of people you respect and you can forget
the rest
yeah i'm writing that down for myself
win the respective people you respect
it's an
excellent reminder you know there are a
thousand people saying you're wrong
but if the two people you respect say
you're right you can ignore the thousand
people
what was the the opening line that you
mentioned in the
uh the purpose-driven life could you
repeat that line for a moment please
it's not about you
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by five
bullet friday it's become one of the
most popular email newsletters in the
world with millions of subscribers
every friday i send out five bullet
points of the coolest things i've found
that week
it's free it's always going to be free
and you can learn more at
dot blog forward slash friday if i'm
doing small
in-person meetups offering early access
to startups beta testing special deals
or anything else
i share it first with five bullet friday
subscribers so
check it out tim dot blog forward slash
friday
again that's tim dot blog forward slash
friday
and thanks for checking it out
this seems to segue
nicely to a number of things that i'd
love to
discuss with you and you know one of the
constructs or
or frameworks i'm not sure if that's the
right label that i'd love to
have you introduce listeners to is the
iwe construct
right not about you it's not about the i
and then there are probably a hundred
different avenues into discussing this
but
feel free to take whatever you think is
a good starting point
yeah you know i i i always
i always when i want to explain things
talk about the joke
that benedict cumberbatch makes in uh
the imitation game you know when he's
playing
alan turing and yeah
great movie you know and and uh keira
knightley
tells him go and tell them a joke you
know show them you're human
and so he goes along and you know he
says you know these two explorers in the
jungle and they suddenly hear a lion raw
and one of them starts looking for a
place where both of them can hide
and the other one starts putting on his
running shoes and the first person says
to the second person
you're crazy yeah you know you can't run
faster than a lion
and the second one turns to the first
one and says i don't need to run
faster than the lion all i need to do is
run faster than you
so um this is
where darwin arrived at that
natural selection where you know there's
competition for scarce resources
where you have to uh outpace others in
order to survive
came to the conclusion that it's the
selfish guy
number two guy who is uh putting on his
running shoes who will survive the lion
whereas it's the first guy the altruist
who's looking
for a way of saving both of them who
gets eaten by the lion so
the ruthless survive and the altruists
go extinct that was darwin's conclusion
and darwin was sharp enough to see
that that conclusion is simply not true
because in every single society that you
ever find
it is the altruists who are admired
so how did altruists survive at all when
natural selection seems to favor the
egoists
and eventually darwin found a solution
he didn't write it in
origin of species he wrote it in his
book the dissented man
and he said any tribe whose members were
altruistic who were
always willing to come to the aid of one
another would be stronger than any tribe
whose members were not altruistic
or as we would put it today we pass on
our genes as individuals but we survive
as groups groups only exist
when we put the we before the eye when
we accept
collective responsibility for the common
good
there is no other way of survival
and since we are social animals since
our existence depends on being
in groups we need altruism in order to
survive
most traditional societies have made
space
for egoism and for altruism
for self-interest and for collective
interest the common good
so the self-interest
is today in the market
where we are competing for wealth and in
politics where we are competing for
power
there it's all about the eye but there's
such a thing
as family or community or congregation
or charity where we are there
not to compete but to cooperate
to function as a collective we now what
has happened in the last 50 years
is that the market is still strong
the state and politics is still strong
but families communities congregations
and the rest have become
weaker than they once were and the end
result is
that we have too much i and too little
we it's all
gone out of balance now
and that is to say that we have pushed
in the west
radical individualism simply
too far what does radical individualism
look like
i don't know are you are you into soccer
in the states
tim or well i used to play
soccer and then spent time in south
america where it's
a religion so i think i'm more exposed
than most
some americans care about soccer but we
tend to
view our football as something you throw
around by hand
but please continue with okay with
soccer since the audience is
international you're watching this you
have a
soccer team that contains the 11
greatest players in the world
but they're all radical individualists
that team will never win a single match
because osaka is made by your ability to
put the team
ahead of the individual player and
imagine an orchestra of radical
individualists the result will not be
music but
will be noise so whenever
i takes over from a place that should be
about we
you get catastrophe now tim
look at this catastrophe and i'm
surprised not more people have noticed
it
two of the countries that have done
worst
in the world in dealing with
the coronavirus pandemic and kovid 19
have been the two most individualistic
societies
in the world today the united states
and the united kingdom the united states
far more
infections than anywhere else far more
fatalities than anywhere else
britain terrible record of fatalities
per million of the population and a
terrible record
of economic collapse now you ask
yourself why these two countries which
were the greatest defenders
of liberty in the 20th century britain
and america
have become the worst at dealing with a
catastrophe like
coronavirus and the answer is they have
too much eye
and too little we it is the countries
that maintain that balance
like south korea like taiwan like
singapore
like new zealand like germany those are
the countries
that have coped really well when you
have a country that is all i
for instance you have political
leadership
that keeps saying i i i instead of
saying
we we a relationship that can sometimes
be very damaging indeed to the social
fabric
so i think as time has gone on
the book that i wrote about this which
of course i finished writing just before
the
pandemic has become more and more
relevant to
where we are and where we ought to be
aiming to be in the future
so the book is morality subtitle
restoring the common good
and divided times and i know you are a
student of history
avid student of history studier of
history and
i can't speak to the feeling the
sentiment
in the uk but in the us i would say
there's a lot of fatalism and nihilism
at the moment certainly including many
people who are well-educated who feel
that you can't put the toothpaste back
in the toothpaste tube
and we are just on the descent
in the lifespan
of a collapsing empire that is i would
say the feeling
that that is very pervasive here and i
would love to know
in your studies to your knowledge are
there any examples
of reversing the trend steering back
away from the precipice
and reverting back to or reinforcing
more we
versus i or is that is that an
unstoppable
one way trend that really can't be
stemmed
tim i want you to i want you to
introduce you
to a jewish way of thinking about things
and that is you're the perfect person to
do it
forget the word inevitable it doesn't
exist forget it delete it
search and delete we are
we're going to come up in a few weeks
time to the jewish higher holidays
right we're going to have rosh hashanah
the jewish new year yom kippur the day
of atonement
and we are going to do the weirdest
thing listen carefully
we are going to say a prayer which goes
on rosh hashanah on the jewish new year
it is written
for the day of atonement it is sealed
who will live who will die he will
prosper who will suffer
the late leonard cohen actually um
made a song about this based on this
called who by fire
so that is the perfect statement of
fatalism you know it's written though
it's going to be written over the next
10 days and there's nothing you can do
about it
and then precisely two minutes later
the entire synagogue erupts with the
words
but prayer penitence and charity
avert the evil decree
nobody ever accepts any verdict
as final in judaism we completely throw
out the concept
of inevitability one of the most moving
things i ever heard
is you know the bbc um
the british army liberated
the extermination camp bergen in the
consecration camp bergen-belsen
in april 1945
and they sent a young journalist called
patrick gordon walker
to do a program a broadcast from
bergen-belsen
just a couple of days after it had been
liberated the people there
were walking corpses
and this was the one of the most
horrendous scenes people had ever
seen but the bbc radio recording of that
still exists and the prisoners the
survivors
can be heard singing a song and the song
they are singing
is hatikva the song that became three
years later
the national anthem of the state of
israel hatikva means the hope
here were people who just just just
managed to survive in a world of corpses
and at the gates of hell they were
singing about hope
that is what judaism is about we never
ever
ever give up hope and we never accept
anything as inevitable
now let me answer your question directly
the last two times
we had a situation as devastating
as this pandemic were 1918
first world war and the spanish flu
pandemic and 1945 the
end of this second world war they could
not have been
less alike in 1918
people didn't change
they went on with an eye-centered
society
they created what we know as the roaring
twenties
with wild dances and wilder parties
there were this
huge economic inequalities and
people tried to blot out the memories of
what had happened by going back to
partying
and just concerned about themselves the
result of that
was the great crash of 1929 the great
depression
of 1930 the rise of nazism and fascism
throughout europe and a mere
21 years after the war to end
all wars the world was at war
again that was 1918
it failed to move from i to we
the world after 1945 was completely
different
it really did move from i to we in
britain
there was the 1944 education act which
extended further education
to all everyone in society a
real major breakthrough against class
divisions
came the national health
service universal health care came
the welfare state in america you had the
gi bill you had all sorts of
measures to help those people who had
made sacrifices during the war
america produced one of the most
imaginative schemes
ever in the marshall plan through which
america extended loans to every country
in europe including germany itself
to rebuild their shattered economies
what was the end result of that 75
years of peace so it can be done
the last time it was done was in 1945 to
1965
the eye society of the 1920s became the
wii society of post-world war ii
and it can be done again i would give
you other examples from the 19th century
but i hope that's enough to be going on
with you
have used the term cultural climate
change
can you define that for people please
cultural climate changes
you know when the ecology the
environment the air the temperature
changes but we very often don't notice
it at once it took a very long time for
people to notice
global warming and climate change there
is a brilliant
professor of sociology at harvard
university called robert putnam whom i
regard
as the world's greatest um sociologist
and robert putnam introduced me to the
concept which i hadn't come across
before of a google engram
a google engram is a way that you can
search
the literature that google has
stored electronically you know they've
made copies of virtually every book
published since
1800 so you can actually search that
literature and
for instance find out the relative
salience
of different words over time and what
robert putnam discovered
was that the word i and the word we
appear
more or less in tandem around the same
sort of level
from 1800 until 1964.
1964 suddenly the eye begins to
predominate over the wee
and when you see something like that you
begin to realize you're in
a state of cultural climate change is
that
good enough for example or would you
like others it is it is
a great example and one of the questions
that comes to my mind is i suppose on a
lot of minds listening to this and that
is what can we do
in countries where rugged individualism
has been prized has been rewarded
when the counter examples say in
whether in china in other locations
reflect thousands of years of
in many cases collective thinking
ancestor worship
etc what can we do there are individual
acts i would imagine
shifts of perspective and then there are
perhaps
larger scale actions we can take but
what would you like to see
us do whether individually or
collectively i think the whole series of
things but
let me give you some examples one thing
that britain took seriously and america
took much
more seriously was the concept of
national identity
there was a kind of initiation that you
went through in
in the states in schools where you learn
what it was to be an
american with the key dates who were the
key people and so on and so forth
i once pointed out this fascinating
experience to walk around the monuments
in washington and then walk around the
monuments
in britain if you walk around the
monuments in washington
you go to lincoln memorial on the one
hand you've got the
gettysburg address on the other the
second inaugural you look at
the jefferson memorial with screeds of
text on
marble tablets you look at the roosevelt
memorial with
those six spaces one for each decade in
public life with the key quotes you know
we have nothing to fear but fear itself
you look at the martin luther
king memorial with well over a dozen of
his most memorable lines
and i suddenly realized in america
monuments is something you read
now go to parliament square in london
and you will find that nelson mandela
gets
three words uh two words sorry
nelson and mandela winston churchill
who wrote as many memorable sentences as
anyone in the english language
gets one word churchill
in britain monuments aren't things you
read
but in america they are why because
america had to integrate successive
waves
of immigration so they had to read the
american story they had to live the
american story
they had to make it their own story
the second you have a strong national
identity then you have a strong
basis for saying we are all in this
together
we all have collective responsibility
for the common good
now around 2016 just before the
presidential election i was privileged
to win quite a big award in the
states in uh presented in the kennedy
center in washington
and i mentioned this story and after i
came down i got my award people said to
me well you know
we used to do that but we have stopped
telling the story now
because we're embarrassed to tell this
story and the moment
i heard that i realized that america was
in
deep trouble because there is no way
you can generate we within society
without a strong sense
of we all belong together all you do is
you
disaggregate and fragment the culture
and the end result is that people like
black lives matter and all the others
feel they are not fully part of this
society
this society doesn't fully recognize and
respect them
you can't live with it so first things
first
tell the story and i was just thinking
can it
really be done and then my beloved
number one daughter who has clearly
divine insight here
decided two years ago or three years ago
that
she was going to buy dad a birthday
present
of tickets for elena myself to go and
see hamilton the musical
and i suddenly realized what it was to
retell the american story in a new and
very inclusive way
so full marks to lin-manuel miranda for
something that is very creative
in expressing the we in a new way so
that's the first thing tell a national
narrative and i fear i've gone on too
long
but i'm happy to tell you the other
stages but um
challenge me if you like oh please do
no challenge top of mind at the moment
so please
please continue okay number two
once you've got this story what next
what next is you need the ritual and the
day
in the diary jews have kept
their identity for longer than any other
people and done so under the more
adverse circumstance of being a tiny
minority a cognitive minority in exile
why did they do it because they have a
day in the year called
passover where they tell the story and
hand it on
to their children jean-jacques rousseau
thought this was the most
remarkable political achievement ever
so you need the day and you need the
moment when you tell the story
i had the privilege of working with we
used to
talk these things through with four
prime ministers with john major with
tony blair with gordon brown
and with david cameron and we
really really looked at this how can we
get this moment in which we enact the
ritual of being all there
together now in britain in november we
have something called remembrance sunday
which is about remembering the people
and the sacrifices
made in war it's very moving the queen
comes all the royal family all prime
ministers
present and previous and everything
everyone is there
just outside 10 downing street it's
televised it's huge
and i said why don't we take this day
and divide it in two
so that the morning is about war and the
past and the afternoon is about peace
and the future and you join them
together by getting the
elderly generation to hand the candle
the flame on
across the generations to young people
and that way we could
find a new and inclusive way of
including young people from
all the ethnic groups and all the
religious groups and it would be a
celebration of britain as a future not
just as a past
we would have the day there in the diary
it would be televised and so on
it never got there i don't know why but
you need not only the story you need the
date in the diary and you need the
ritual
and then thirdly and this is far and
away the most
important you need to empower
young people the way to teach young
people how to be moral
is to just send them to disaster zones
to to people who need care and empower
them
show that you believe in them the way
the laboratory ever believed in me
because once you empower people and you
give them the opportunity
to make the world better by their
altruism
they learn that much more powerfully by
doing it for themselves
than by getting a lecture on it so you
put those three things together a
national story
a national ritual and empowerment of
young people for something
a little like national service
and you would bring back the wii
immediately
this is such an important subject i'm so
thrilled that you've penned this book
and while we still have a little bit of
time
i'd love to hop from empowering to
perhaps an aspect
of empowering or at the very least not
disempowering although you can
re-contextualize if you like
i know you have written i believe in
this most recent book
about safe spaces cancel culture
free speech is there anything that you
would like to say
on these subjects yeah there is nothing
less
safe than safe space
i was i told you rather inspired
by the lubavitch and i became as a
graduate student in cambridge quite
religious
my postgraduate my doctoral supervisor
was sir bernard williams widely regarded
as the most brilliant man in britain and
the
leading philosopher in the world of his
generation
and bernard williams was a lapsed
catholic and
a ferocious atheist and a brilliant
atheist
and here he is talking to a young man
with a beard and a velvet yum okay you
know
it was crazy and in all the time we were
together
never once did he ridicule my beliefs
not once
all he wanted to do was could i make
them coherent
lucid consistent that's all and my
goodness me
the fact that i was being tutored by
somebody who regarded
every single thing that i believed
as superstitious nonsense but it was
totally courteous to me
and genuinely so it went deep down that
was safe space
because it meant i could face the world
knowing that there are lots of people
who will disagree with me and i am
completely unafraid
because i sat with a guy much more
intelligent than any of them
whose views were much more opposed to
mine than any of them
and we were able to talk respectfully
and i realized what is safe space
a place where you listen respectfully
to the views of those who disagree with
you
because you know in return they will
listen respectfully
to your views even though they're
opposed to them
safe space means that courteous
discipline of respectful listening
which is being shredded and defiled
in too many universities today what they
are doing
is creating very very unsafe space
you know there's an interesting thing
that lots and lots of kids say is this
true in the states
in britain it is lots and lots of young
children have
peanut allergies true in the us as well
yeah there's one country in the world
where kids don't have peanut allergies
and that is israel because the most
popular snack
in israel contains peanuts so because
they're exposed to it
from very early on they develop immunity
to it
and because at university we are exposed
to views
that challenge our own we develop
immunity to it and that is what makes us
strong
and healthy and safe and people are
going to go through our university
system thinking
that the world is a place where if you
protest
long and loudly enough on twitter or
instagram or
or facebook you can cancel out
any view with which you disagree not
only are you destroying
the most important element of
civilization which is the collaborative
pursuit of truth
but you are also potentially ruining
those young people
you have to make them intellectually
robust
and don't carry on with what you're
doing because frankly what you're doing
is
an outrage and i do believe that
universities are so
important to the health of a society
that
the guardians of those places should
show a lot more courage
now there's a there's a saying that is
in some notes
from i believe this this new book audi
ultra impartum
yeah and now i'm i'm not up to speed in
my latin i'm
assuming that's latin hear the other
side
thank you
and you know you're following that and
uh please correct me if i'm getting any
of this incorrect but no institution
that denies a hearing to the other side
can be a vehicle for justice
yeah it's a principle of roman law
listen to the other side
there's a story i tell actually um that
perhaps i could repeat
from the book it's from the talmud and
from trite
it tells of two study partners one was
called rabbi yochanan and one was called
and they used to discuss jewish law
every day
and then reisha akish died and the
rabbis were really worried about rabbi
yochanan who was a very important rabbi
of the third century
because they thought that without his
study partner
he would uh go into a depression and die
so they said we have to find him a study
partner to cheer him up
and so they sent him a rabbi eliasa ben
padat
who knew the whole literature backwards
and forwards
and whenever rabbi yochanan expressed an
opinion rabbi eleazar ben padat would
say
there is a source that supports you
after two days of this rabbi yochman
started tearing his hair out
and saying rachel arkis come back
they've sent me this guy who whenever i
say anything
says you're right do you think i don't
know i'm right do i need him to tell me
i'm right
but when you were here ray schlockish
every sat time i would express an
opinion you would show me
24 reasons why i was wrong
and i would have to find 24 reasons to
show i was right
and the end result is that you grew and
i grew
so please take this man away
[Laughter]
it's it reminds me of a concept called
red teaming
that a lot of the best investors also
use and i think that
investment here is just a metaphor for
life and that is they
will in say partner meetings or
otherwise get into the etymology of it
which is military
but having your partners
your colleagues do their best
to attack your beliefs systems position
assumptions and only once
they have been thoroughly thoroughly
stress tested can you truly understand
your position
and can you truly have confidence in
your position and there are a number of
other things
in this new book that struck me i'm
looking i'm picking and choosing and
cherry picking a little bit here like a
monument in the united states of course
but
you know free society depends on the
dignity of descent i think the phrasing
of that is so important
and later on persist with all your heart
and soul any attempt to substitute power
for truth and stay far from people
movements and parties
that demonize their opponents and it
makes me
think as a student of history or
sometimes student of history myself i
try to
read as much as i can that
things in excess often become their
opposite right so without
stress testing freedom fighters become
tyrants you know
things become their opposite and it's
it's very easy
for someone who starts with what they
deem good intentions
to forcibly suppress opposition and
forget that forcible
suppression of opposition is it perhaps
the defining characteristic of fascism
and it's it's terrifying it really is um
it really is terrifying and i i'm glad
that you're
you're speaking to all these points in
the context
of moving from i to we which is
sort of by definition inclusive if that
makes sense
the um you know the the founders of
america
and indeed the founders of liberty in
the modern world the john miltons and
john locke's
the um thomas jefferson's that the
washingtons and of course that wonderful
man
um i mean madison and so on forever all
these papers
they they were about you know separation
of powers
about faction about not vesting
full power in this institution all that
but
forcing people to maintain a delicate
balance
now you have too much we
you get china and you lose freedom you
have too much i
and you get the states in britain today
which have just gone a little
too far maintaining the balance between
i and we
is not easy it's a constant it's a
constant challenge
and it seems to me that that we just
took our eye off the ball
and an imbalance suddenly appeared
and you know all of a sudden things that
i took for granted forever
i can no longer take for granted like
the fact that liberal democracy is here
to stay
and it's the default condition of human
affairs
and you suddenly realize it isn't so
that actually
our situation today certainly in britain
and america is quite delicate
and um truth is we've all got to play
our part
you know when you feel that that
something as tiny
as that original instance of of
coronavirus
was able to sweep across the world
and that of course is a kind of medical
example of what people call the
butterfly effect the chaos theory that
the beating of a butterflies wing in the
philippines can cause a tidal wave on
the west coast of america
but i profoundly believe the other way
around as well
i once in a book called it the chaos
theory
of virtue that every good deed
we do somehow has an impact
on people it changes them for the better
they pay it forward
and although we may not realize it
the good we do is contagious just as the
bad we do is
and therefore we can each make a
positive difference to this
and perhaps it's only we the people
who can do it here here
it's um it strikes me as much easier to
destroy
than to create and there there is
perhaps a natural entropy to
many of these systems and it takes
effort
it takes effort to to keep things on the
rails
and i think it's i think it's a good
time to measure twice and cut once
and it brings to mind one of the quotes
which is from you there's an ellipses in
the middle because there's more to this
statement so i don't want to shortchange
it but
you know the single most important
distinction in life dot dot dot
is to distinguish between an opportunity
to be seized and a temptation to be
resisted and
i feel like you have illustrated
throughout your career
the ability to pause and reflect
before taking action not that you always
do that of course you're human
but it seems like that is is good
medicine for
our times and circumstances right now
and i know we only have a few minutes
left for very good reasons
and i want to give just a teaser for a
potential round two with you
before we go to some closing comments
but in the course of doing homework
came across something i wanted to ask
you how long did you
date your now wife before
getting engaged or proposing i think it
was three weeks
certainly certainly wasn't before
okay so we're gonna bookmark the most
unlike me i have ever encountered
and this summer despite lockdown we
celebrated our golden wedding
so there you are congratulations
congratulations
and perhaps next time we'll also have
you tell us more about the ritual
of reading the 10 plagues in the
passover service which as
as someone who's really not been exposed
to any of this i found
i found beautiful and and in fact maybe
that is a
maybe that is a decent inclusion for
for this conversation if you have just a
few minutes more
do you think that is worth mentioning or
describing for people
well or should we hold that for around
two yeah they're shedding to the
spilling uh uh drops of wine on the
passover night
as we tell the story of the exodus and
as we read the templates
has many different explanations
so this one is certainly not the only
explanation
but one explanation was
that we shed tears for the egyptians who
died
during that period because
we take no pleasure in the suffering of
our enemies
and we do not rejoice in the victims
of our victories and i think that's a
really important thing
to do somehow or other
to say to yourself okay i'm jewish but
what are what
about those egyptians they weren't
responsible for pharaoh they weren't
responsible for the slavery
and yet he had driven the country to the
brink of disaster
and i think that that kind of role
reversal
do you know what i mean tim when you
think your way
to your enemy and suddenly realize that
your enemy is human like you are and
has a point of view as you do although
it's not the same point of view
it's very difficult and very challenging
but
it is very powerful the contemporary
example
that comes to mind is that um
what is it
um there was a leader of the jobic party
in hungary
the anti-semitic party in hungary
his name was uh it's just
zanard zegedi and
he was a fully fledged anti-semite
but he had some enemies within the party
and they decided to see if they could
dig up
any embarrassing facts in his background
and lo and behold they discovered that
this guy
unknown to him his grandparents had died
at auschwitz that hungary's leading
anti-semite
was a jew well i mean today this is a
religious jew
who spent his life fighting a new life
fighting anti-semitism
but it just shows how powerful it can be
if you suddenly think yourself
into a different situation and if we
were capable of that we would
rid the world of a great deal of
violence
rabbi sacks it is always such a pleasure
i've greatly enjoyed all of our
interactions i hope we
may have many more and share a cup of
tea perhaps at some point in person
post pandemic or when things get under
more control the new book which i highly
recommend
people check out is titled morality
subtitle restoring the common good
and divided times i can think of nothing
more important
right now in embracing
this and shifting from i to we not
necessarily from one extreme to the
other but certainly
further along the spectrum towards a
collective we
people can find you at rabbissacks.org
at rabbi sacks
on all social twitter instagram facebook
youtube
is there anything else that you would
like to say before we
close for today yeah of course i want to
thank you tim
for writing the most wonderful books
for asking the most unbelievably
engrossing questions
and um as i told you for doing a little
video for my son
who is your biggest fan and who
introduced me
to your work since when i have become
your biggest fan thank you so much i
really
appreciate you i appreciate what you're
doing in the world
and i appreciate your time today and for
everyone listening we will have complete
show notes linking to everything
including the new book any resources
people who are mentioned
at tim dot blog forward slash podcast
thank you
again rabbi sachs may we have many more
conversations
and to everyone listening thank you for
tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that i've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up in
the uh the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include favorite articles that
i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
freshbooks thousands of listeners and a
lot of the contractors i use
and my readers use freshbooks if you've
been thinking about turning your
part-time side business into a full-time
small business
or big business for that matter you may
be feeling some extra uncertainty these
days
and that's obviously completely natural
there are a lot of questions that can
come up how do you create a professional
appearance and experience
who can help you with support how do you
manage the billing and all of that but
still focus
on the primary work of your business and
on growing your business
freshbooks is an all-in-one invoicing
and accounting solution
it does a lot more than that that helps
you take your business from part-time to
full-time and it only takes
minutes to set up they have one of the
best sign-up flows
in the business i've seen very few
better they have been helping people
turn their passions into small
businesses for 15 years
and they can help you too i've met the
founders i've looked at this product
very closely with automated invoicing
billable time and expense tracking
and an intuitive dashboard that ties it
all together it's like having a
full-time
financial assistant with you every step
of the way
you can create customize and send
branded and professional looking
invoices in about
30 seconds you get paid up twice as fast
with fees
as low as one percent using ach payments
on freshbooks
it's a fast easy and secure way for
clients to pay you for your work
and pay you more quickly one of the many
things that sets freshbooks apart is
their award-winning toronto-based
customer service a real person picks up
fast and will help you until you are
completely satisfied and have your
questions answered there's a lot of
uncertainty in the world right now
but your ability to build a business
that you're passionate about that you're
proud of
doesn't have to be one of those things
business owners all over the world
rate freshbooks as the easiest
accounting software to use
try it out check it out for free for 30
days at freshbooks.com
tim just enter tim ferriss in the how
did you hear about us section
again that's freshbooks.com tim to check
it out and try it for free for 30 days
one more time
freshbooks.com tim
this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleeve
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude
it is the end-all be-all that all good
things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and for the last few years
i've been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
in like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helix sleep.com
tim take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free or even pick it up from you if
you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off
and two free pillows at
helixsleep.comtim
that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com tim for
up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
you